[Musique]
dans le hall du palais de la source une
exposition surprenante accueille les
élus du conseil départemental des
productions d'enfants qui sont le fruit
de l'action des travailleurs sociaux du
département dans le sud cette action
sert effectivement à pouvoir mettre des
mots sur ce que les enfants perçoivent
sur la notion de violence puisque la
violence est récurrente dans les
familles et sur un aspect aussi éducatif
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de l'hémicycle les
travailleurs sociaux sont invités à
participer au débat
l'objectif étant de voter le schéma
départemental d'orientation sociale et
médico sociale et la stratégie nationale
de prévention et de protection de
l'enfance des documents qui renforce
ronde notamment l'action de prévention
médico social infantile chez les femmes
enceintes et dans les écoles maternelles
à travers les pmi concrètement cela veut
dire deux fois plus de femmes enceintes
accompagné deux fois plus d'enfants
bénéficiant d'un suivi médical en
centres de pmi
ça veut dire passer de 70 % à 100 % des
enfants de 3,4 en vue dans le cadre des
bilans de santé en école maternelle et
ça veut dire aussi renforcer la qualité
des interventions pouvoir avoir de
nouveaux professionnels comme des
psychologues en pmi comme des
interventions de travailleurs
d'intervention sociale et familiale ces
deux mesures de partenariat voté à
l'unanimité représente un coup
d'accélérateur à l'action de terrain
mais cela permet également une récolte
d'informations pour mieux agir demain la
réalité ça donne aujourd'hui une
coordination et une mutualisation des
moyens qu en plus renforcée faut lutter
conte l'enfance en danger je m'explique
on voit bien que le département dans le
cadre de sa mission régater de
prévention et de protection de l'enfance
depuis de longues dates travaille sur la
mise en place du dispositif notamment
des dispositifs innovants et aujourd'hui
le partenariat avec l'agent régionale de
santé les états vient amener des moyens
complémentaires à ceux du département
pour mettre l'accent sur des actions
déterminantes notamment en direction du
tout petit près de 6000 enfants
bénéficient dans des dispositifs de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance et depuis
2013 les dossiers ont augmenté de 9%
de quoi s'atteler également à l'avenir
des jeunes majeurs de la zone le
maillage territorial
l'action sociale la collectivité temps
ainsi de répondre à une vraie
problématique sociétale
[Musique]